hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played in the first
match uh the first quarterfinal match
between Yankees of Duda and Hikaru
Nakamura of the chess.com Global Chess
Championship Finals uh and this is game
four of their first match so they will
play two matches each consisting of four
games and in the first match Hikaru won
the first three games and here in the
fourth game Duda chose a very very
interesting approach to the game as he
chooses the bong Cloud opening now uh
regarding the bonecloud the the real
question is how bad is it is it if you
play the bomb Cloud if you put your King
on E2 are you is your accomplish a
position that lost now uh it should be
definitely but I always uh you know when
I hear stuff like that I remember some
20 something years ago when I first
started learning just when I when I got
my first chess book I remember a line
from the two knights defense I'm sure
you all know it uh I mean it's uh
probably the first thing you learn when
you start learning chess Knight F3
Knight the C6 Bishop C4 9 like to F6 and
now white goes for Knight G5 the
so-called Knight attack black will reply
with d5e captures on D5 and now usually
you attack with Knight's day 5 where we
go Knights to D4 or Knights the beef or
even but most certainly you do not
capture with Knight captures on D5
because some 20 years ago if you saw
this position uh it was known that
Knight captures an F7 and black just
resigns and there are many lines where
black just resigns completely for
example let's say you capture the knight
uh Queen F3 uh your king goes here let's
say queen captures Queen captures and
Bishop captures this Checkmate and
that's uh all very nice you probably won
a lot of games like this but the problem
is after Queen to F3 check yes you are
attacking the Knight twice and you are
threatening uh to just win it win back
your piece and your you have a better
position but what if the black plays
just King E6 and defends the Knight it
looks like it breaks every principle
known to man uh about Chess and that you
should not be able to play like this
however it is not clear here how to
punish this of course if you are in an
incredibly strong player you will
outplay your opponent from this position
but if you play against the superior
opponent or let alone if you try beating
an engine from this position you will
fail miserably because okay you have
some pressure here the king is an E6 but
how to continue this game Let's zero
Knight to C3 you put pressure on the
Knight already Knight before is coming
the Knight is now nicely defended you're
already threatening Knight captures and
C2 with check let's say White Castles
You're Gonna Play C6 defend your knight
and yes your king is an E6 but you will
play some moves you will bring the queen
to F6 or for a queen trade and the white
has to prove that he can actually win
this position now of course uh if you've
seen games uh from the previous era of
chess games of Paul Murphy games of
Adolf Anderson they if their opponents
played such moves they will of course
get crushed but in modern chess if our
good friend the engine says yes it's
okay it's perfectly fine you can put
your King on E6 and have a comfortable
game then we have no choice but to
listen to them but what about the bong
Cloud so Duda opens the game with E3 we
have pawned the E5 by Hikaru and now do
the place King to E2 now this is uh this
is uh even more disgusting that what
I've just shown you yeah because now you
are uh the the whole point of developing
your Pawn to E3 or E4 is so the queen
and Bishop have a very natural way of uh
accessing the game but now by putting
the king Anita you are you are you are
voluntarily blocking your entire
development and the white very very
quickly runs out of moves so how does
Hikaru punish this he plays Pawn to D5
he grabs the full Center and why not do
that allows it and now there are even
some classical games that reach this
position where D3 and queen T1 was was
played but here Duda plays Pawn to D4
and it is now as of move three that we
have a completely new game and okay you
could consider capturing captures
captures to open up the white King's
position but as Hikaru is already up
three to zero wrote he just continues
development he says okay you can't play
like this I don't have to rush this or
find some sort of a clean win uh you're
just gonna fail miserably so Knight to
C3 Knight F6 by Hikaru we have F3 you
have to create some squares for your
king because as long as the kingan is an
E2 you've already basically finished
your development you can develop the
Queen the bishop the Knight I mean it's
it's terrible so Bishop to D6 we have
King to F2 a must move uh we have
castles and not Knight G to E2 we have
Queen to E7 by Hikaru just putting
pieces on optimal squares and not Knight
to B5 uh we have Bishop to B4 not
allowing the knights to capture the
bishop Pawn the C3 Bishop A5 and now
Pawn to a for trying to trap the bishop
with B4 and A5 so Hikaru just shifts it
over to B6 and now Pawn to H3 taking
away the G4 Square once again from from
Black's pieces uh A6 chases away the
Knight 93 and now Knight the E8 Hikaru
is now ready to start pushing further in
the center with Pawn to F5 we have
pawned the B4 by Duda Knight to D6 and
now Pawn the G3 give Duda like 15 more
moves and he will even castle kingside
with Rook to E1 and now Rook the A2 this
is a a very nice move uh the The Rook
will be much more useful on the second
Rank and also it's very difficult to
develop it but as long as it's on the
first rank Plus in the future if the
position ever opens up on the king side
you might even shift it over to attack
the black king that's a weird Arrow I I
know so Queen to F6 by Hikaru we have
King to G2 and now Bishop to F5
uh the bishop could also be developed uh
to D7 if you don't want to allow any G4
with Tempo but hikarus is not a problem
so G4 Bishop to G6 and not Knight the G3
and already you can sense that duda's
position is improving a little bit the
Knight okay still an A3 The Rook can be
shifted over to the king side if Paul if
needed the bishop can be developed a D3
to counter he carves bishop and G6 so
Hikari is still better here of course
but uh he he has to play a very precise
moves and here he plays Ponta H5 it's a
pawn sacrifice uh aimed at uh attacking
the white king but it's also a move that
completely uh or maybe close to
completely levels the game uh if Duda
continues uh the game properly but this
is also one of the reasons why uh humans
cannot play against the uh not against
uh humans cannot play like engines here
you have to completely ignore that your
king is on G2 and you have to
voluntarily open up the G file but this
will be used to attack the black king
not the white king now this was not
played in the game but this is what you
have to play if you already want to play
like an engine then you have to think
like an engine Bishop to H7 A5 attacks
the bishop Bishop A7 and now came to H2
and now look at this with the semi-openg
file The Rook can come to G1 the other
Rook can come to G2 if black ever
captures here to open up the position
your Bishop is already uh freed up to
help with the attack on the black king
the pawn is coming to H6 uh I mean it's
it is just a very nice position for for
white it's black is still better here
but this is the way to play however Duda
tried Rook the G1 and now Hikaru I I
believe he was very happy here uh
advances the pawn to H4 because he knows
that g captures on H5 will be a problem
for him so H4 and now Knight to E2 and
now all of those ideas that we discussed
with the semi-openg file no longer exist
and now Duda is just in a much much
worse position 8 the d8 was played the
chapter D2 and now Knight the sea for
Hikaru offering a trade of knights which
you pretty much have to accept but then
the pawn comes to C4 and you create an
outpost for your Bishop on D3 Soul
Knight captures in c4d captures Pawn to
A5 and now Bishop to A7 we have Queen to
E1 and now comes Bishop to D3 uh
interestingly okay this is a rapid game
so you don't have all the time in the
world to think about what you will play
I will just show it because I know you
guys like seeing fun lines here you can
just blast through with uh e-captress on
D4 for example e captures now even
Bishop captures on D4 and look at this C
captress Knight captures and what is the
white to do here there's no way you can
survive this if Bishop comes to D3 uh
also if you play some like Queen Tiff to
even Knight captures and F3 can be
played look at this disgusting if Queen
captures Bishop E4 and white can just
resign but okay after Queen E1 Hikaru
that slowly mounts pressure Bishop to D3
we have Queen to F2 and now Knight to E7
we have knighted the C1 puts pressure on
the bishop and Bishop captures on F1
Rook captures and now Knights the D5 so
again just slowly building uh the
pressure and again Duda could grab some
initiative here by advancing the pawn to
E4 if Knight F4 then you're gonna
capture Queen captures and now Knight E2
you kick away the queen and after the
queen moves let's say queen H6 now you
play Rook to D1 and all of a sudden
white is alive but after Knight E5 Duda
played Knight to E2 and now Queen to E7
by Hikaru with rooked the E1 and now
Pawn to C6 so Hikaru really slow playing
this and you can't blame him he's up
three three zero in the match and he
wants to play a normal chest he just
doesn't want to blunder anything because
it's uh best of two matches and they
will play four more games so uh even if
uh Duda loses terribly he still wants to
maximize his profit for from the first
match Rook to B2 by Duda and now we have
e captures on D4 we have Knight captures
on D4 and now Queen to F6 uh Rook B to
B1 and now Pawn to G6 we have King to H1
and now Rook to D7 uh Rook D2 We have
Bishop captures on D4 and now E Capture
Sun D4 you could also play C count first
then you allow C3 Bishop D1 and it looks
um well it just looks very very bad for
white but maybe white can still hold
this however after e captures on D4 it
is just um over it is uh you can win
this by four so root captures an E2
Queen captures Rook D7 attacks the queen
queen F2 and not Knight the F for
attacking the H3 Pawn going for Knight
to D3 so you kind of have to capture the
Knights of Bishop captures Queen
captures and now Rook to F1 as you know
Rook to E3 is coming so the F3 Pawn
should be protected uh but still what do
you do about the C3 Pawn this will just
give Hikaru a past C pawn queen captures
on H4 we have Rook captures on C3 and
now Queen to d8 with check with King to
G7 King G2 and now Rook the C2 with
check Rook F2 Rook captures King
captures and now Fanta C3 and he was in
this position on move 40 foreign
as there is nothing more to be done C2
is coming and then C1 is already guarded
by the by The Black Queen and you cannot
stop promotion of the pawn and you can't
give any checks so that's that that's
all there is uh but as you've seen there
were many many chances for Duda to seize
initiative especially this this was such
a such a wonderful opportunity after
Hikaru pushed that pawn to H5
uh but uh dude just uh missed it here uh
just open up the position the H5 Pawn is
guarded and then all of the
possibilities uh are there but now after
allowing Hikaru to advance the pawn all
the way to H4 any Duda and any counter
play Duda might have had uh you know
just uh disappeared along with hikaru's
Pawn from H5 so really really
interesting stuff you can see that it's
not all that clear how to punish the
bone Cloud even Hikaru who I believe has
even studied the bond Cloud as he's a
true student of the game uh was unable
to punish it by force uh but one of the
reasons being that this is a speed chess
and also he's winning the match by a
huge margin uh but it's not uh I mean
you have to be careful but on the other
hand if you want to try and play like an
engine it is possible it's just that in
positions like that you have to also do
what the engine would do you have to
open up your king you have to say uh
like in that position there that we
discussed here rapper King characters on
F7 and queen to F3 check you go King E6
and you say this is perfectly fine I'm
okay here I mean my king is such a
strong piece here fighting for the
center you know helping out my pieces
this is this is good chess uh but yeah
of course when you play against someone
uh who is as strong as Hikaru pulling
off the bomb Cloud would be would be a
spectacular feat however here it um well
it just wasn't dude as they uh but yeah
if you guys want to try it out you're
welcome to do so because sometimes when
your opponents you put your king I need
to they will just lash out they will
throw everything at you at once but it's
not possible to just crush your opponent
like that if you play good moves you
will be able to defend and then your
opponent might over commit a little bit
and you will be able to even win the
game easily who knows uh but yeah very
interesting uh to see this played at the
absolute highest level by the by by the
candidates of the World Chess
Championship dude and Hikaru Nakamura in
the second match uh Hikaru only had to
get a draw from the four games that were
played and Duda even started by winning
the first game then dude that won the
second game and it looked like Duda was
uh about to achieve maybe an impossible
comeback from a 4-0 downfall but then
Hikaru just ended to do the streak in
game three and then uh he won their
quarterfinal match uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it be careful
uh if you play the bone Cloud but be
even more careful if you face the bone
Cloud it's not as easy as it seems uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh I would like to thank
Jacob Robo Martin your paparik's office
versus
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up any
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day